hey guys it's Justine and it is about a
year anniversary since I moved into my
new studio and do you want to know how
many things that I wanted to do when I
first moved in here that I haven't done
yeah that's right A lot of them thank
you to AMD and Corsair for sponsoring a
portion of this video but one thing that
I have done over the past couple of
weeks is I decided that I was not going
to do anything else no other work no
playing video games until I cleaned and
organized my studio now the main reason
for this is one of the rooms I had
dedicated to be a podcast studio and
well it never actually ended up being a
podcast Studio it was kind of overflow
storage so I got all of that stuff of
cleaned up I got my new gaming office
and soon I'll have my editing Suite all
set up but to celebrate we have a new
gaming laptop in the studio today to
check out I'm so excited about this when
I saw the creative brief and how awesome
this looks I could not wait to get my
hands on it now as you guys know a few
video games have recently come out at
Call of Duty being one of them so I've
been playing that a ton and I'm going to
be traveling for the holidays and I
don't like traveling with my console so
I'm really excited because a lot of the
games that I've been playing recently
are across platform compatible so I can
still play with my friends who are on
Console so let's open this up and check
it out
okay what do we have here we have a
t-shirt that's a sweet little treat
we've got our power brick power adapter
oh we have a mouse pad and this is
actually very very nice this is like an
industrial high quality Mouse patch I'm
hyped about that
here it is oh yeah we still have another
gift there's another gift before we even
get to the laptop
hello a laptop cover
this is beautiful first of all can we
just talk about the color scheme this
matches my new office I actually painted
one of the walls pink this is gonna look
so good
look how pretty it is
[Music]
this is the Corsair Voyager a1600 AMD
Advantage Edition laptop it has an AMD
ryzen 6000 series processor with AMD
Radeon RX 6800m mobile Graphics this
display is so beautiful it's a 16 inch
QHD plus display with 240Hz refresh rate
for super responsive and smooth gaming
these integrated s keys right here are
powered by Elgato stream deck software I
love using the stream deck on my desktop
but now I don't even have to bring it
with me when I travel it's right here
and easily accessible when I'm streaming
I also really like corsair's IQ software
that lets you customize your system's
look or monitor performance and even
update any of your Corsair devices it's
super quiet due to Vapor chamber Cooling
and has support for three simultaneous
external 4K displays it's got a full HD
webcam and noise canceling microphone
array so you're ready to stream right
out of the box
[Music]
I mean this thing's beautiful I mean
this is my aesthetic a hundred percent
so now this is all set up let me show
you the rest of the office and what's
been happening here behind the scenes
Jenna have you seen my new laptop
um I was just I have my little eyes on
it because it's very nice I know I'm
really excited about it this is cool
because you could like do you know what
this is this is integrated stream deck
so when you're streaming like this is
like these you can custom make them do
whatever you want so Jenna's here we're
gonna set up the new podcast room but
the problem is there's literally nothing
in it there's no lighting we don't even
have chairs so you guys are basically
seeing the beginning of the podcast room
yeah I've got my little eyes on what's
Happening Here this is cool dude I know
I'm really excited about it of course we
can play Call of Duty oh
we've been playing I'm gonna take this
home for the holidays yeah and play from
here
it's gonna be great so let me show you
guys what we've got going on here this
is basically like my gaming room which
we'll talk about that in a bit but this
is the podcast room
it's empty
let's make this a new home
everything has been freshly organized
you love podcast days don't you
wow
very loud and echoey
[Music]
table Mike what I was thinking
but that's a boring white wall
[Music]
foreign
oh
hey buddy that leaf is
please
[Music]
I feel like I need to move over a little
so do you done
the big reveal Isn't it nice this is so
temporary like so many things need to
change it looks pretty decent on camera
but I've got my little laptop stand here
we're gonna get this fully tricked out
and it's gonna be awesome I'm so excited
but everything seems to be set up enough
to make a functional podcast
are you ready for this yeah this isn't
in the shower like the bucket
um
you look great where's Maddie
he's under the desk come on she's got a
bed for you go see look you're you're
included go ahead he is gonna end up on
your lap
that was kind of hard that's a hard
scrap hey guys it's Justine and I'm
Jenna welcome to the same brain podcast
let's roll that intro
it's so great okay it's a new war zone
2.0 okay so here's the thing all right
so I just got this new laptop I'm
actually super excited about this so
cute it's this Corsair Voyager now look
like look at this thing first of all I
open this up and I lost my mind like
look how it's so nice like this color
like this is it's like printed on but it
the way that it's printed it looks like
real and then when I flip this around
this has these built-in s keys and those
are linked to like the Elgato stream
deck so you basically have an integrated
stream deck this is like ready to go
it's so great so I'm bringing this home
for the holidays it's really really nice
yeah it's not that heavy does it have a
built-in SD card too it does nice USBC
USB it's great it's really really nice
and it matches my new office I got
painted
foreign
office look and yes my printer is
sitting in the corner with some printed
out papers I do need to get something to
fix that but here is my desk this is the
whole setup that I have with the new
Corsair Voyager I absolutely love the
look of this the LED lights are such a
nice fun touch but the best part about
this is the fact that I can use external
monitors so I have two monitors hooked
up to this currently as you can see here
this is where I'm gonna be playing my
game and this is my old stream deck
which I don't need to use anymore
because I already have one built into
the Corsair not only do I use the road
caster for the podcasting but I do use
it for my stream setup and I know I'm
playing on a PC but I'm using a
controller judge me if you would like
but I don't really care because I like
to play with controller and here's the
setup from behind I also wanted to test
it out playing directly on the laptop
and mirroring it with the monitor in the
background and here it is it worked
great with a mirror display and I also
wanted to try it out without the
mirrored display which is mostly how
I'll be playing over the holiday season
this was such a fun video I hope you
guys enjoyed it I'll put a link in the
description if you want to get more
information about the Corsair Voyager
and I will see you guys in my next video
[Music]